i want to make sure i mention this
because this is really funny bull twit
and whatnot you got a copy i got a copy
uh
this is fine i did not send you a hard
copy this is the hard copy
i'm more proud of the quality of the
book than i am of some of the jokes in
hey there colin i'm so stupid this is
the hardcover right
uh-huh when you buy this book this book
is 140
and people i do stupid stuff because i'm
stupid
140 because of 140 characters and
people are buying the book because it's
a great table piece and it's the quality
as you can see the quality of your paper
cover
is really good there yeah you know i i
like a paperback because
uh i get nervous if the book is uh if
it's too fancy i feel like i don't
deserve it so i'm i'm comfortable with
the paperback well you don't deserve it
that's why i sent you this one
go ahead sir yeah you sent me the
paperback thanks a lot
we used to live in the same building and
i i get the paperback uh can i read some
of these because i really like them i
like this one
i'll straight up link with someone from
grindr and grind with someone from
linkedin i really don't give a [ __ ]
about that i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i'll eat cupcakes out of a
pan and pancakes out of a cup
i don't play by the rules okay i like
this one i like the really silly ones
just saying
sweater vests are gonna have to pick a
side when the [ __ ] goes down between
sweaters and vests
guess what there's some really good uh i
like the
the the there's some silly strange ones
here's one i don't play the whack-a-mole
game at carnivals because it reminds me
of when my family was attacked by moles
and i was unable to defend them
you know what that must be a really
funny joke because that's also
pat oswalt's funniest joke oh really
yeah i'm just trying to make you pee a
little bit from your eye
uh-huh
you have an idea i mean some of these
also are really good
uh you know i started my career as a
sketch writer
i had to write sketches long before i
had to write jokes and
there's great sketch ideas in here this
is a tweet you sent that i think would
make a great sketch i'd like to see this
happen why do football players only
dance when good [ __ ] happens
just once i want to see a quarterback
throw an interception
and do a sad interpretive dance
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be nice no but i mean
that's a funny sketch i would love to
see someone do that that's a great idea
it really is a great idea and you know
when you see these tweets that i do in
the book
it's not my tweets it's the replies the
reply is i'm going to write
um more bull twit volume two and whatnot
like i s uh shout out to the top five
bells in the world
so i did liberty bell i did tinker bell
i did save by the bell
i did a few more bells and then somebody
hit me with you never heard of taco
that drives me crazy little things like
a taco bell yes
and the next book i'm gonna add some of
those replies like if i were to do the
top five codes in the world
codes the top five codes in the world
you see this from coming aren't you
sure you got costco yeah you got uh uh
co-mingling you got uh co-op
and i guess number five would be conan
yes
how about number one instead of number
five let's go don't push it
don't push it
[Laughter]
you're pushing i you know what you know
what george i got greedy
uh i got i got ahead of myself and i i
apologize